excuse me excuse me we're celebrities  where we have to go we're celebrities  Britney Spears and Ellen DeGeneres  caused chaos at a local mall on  Wednesdays episode of The Ellen  DeGeneres Show the two jokingly proof  set stars they're not just like no no  celebrity adjoin about parking in the  legal parking space yep lay in a display  bed of course so this would be 100%  discount because she's a celebrity from  work okay great  Britney hits the mall with Ellen in  promotion for her new album glory but  the pop star might have also hit on  Diplo on Twitter the mom of two saw a  pic of the musician shirtless using the  Britney snapchat filter and wrote  looking good on that board hope to see  you at piece of meat soon Diplo replied  saying they told me you were better at  it than me hmm maybe there's a Diplo  Britney romance in our future or at  least a collab right